hi i'm kristen goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown as states across
the nation ease coronavirus restrictions
president trump says he is planning to
resume campaign rallies this month
trump campaign communications director
tim murtaugh joins the rundown
to discuss the commander-in-chief's
re-election strategy shifting the
campaign to a virtual setting
and addresses criticism of the
president's response to protests over
the death of george floyd
and november isn't just the presidential
election
fox news politics editor and co-host of
the i tell you what podcast
chris stirewalt breaks down this year's
key congressional races
the battle for control of the senate and
ticket splitting
plus commentary by fox news contributor
and pastor of first
baptist church in dallas robert jeffress
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to
i'm foxnewspodcast.com chalu i'm sandra
smith i'm steve ducey and this
is the fox news rundown
[Music]
wednesday june 10th 2020 i'm jessica
rosenthal
after a tumultuous few months the biden
campaign appears to pick up some steam
but the trump campaign says their
numbers tell a different story as they
get ready to
campaign again for real having a trump
rally
uh is really uh would be a message to
america
that we can get back to the way that
things were before the global pandemic
hit
i'm lisa brady this year's multiple
national crises
could shake up a lot more than the
presidential race especially for any
republicans
wanting to cut coattails if you are
running for
senate if you're running for governor if
you're running for the house
at some point do you start to separate
yourself do you start to say you need to
keep me
because the democratic lunatics are
going to take over and i'm the only
thing that can protect you
and i'm robert jeffress i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it's been quite a year already and it's
not even halfway over
rebooting 2020 jokes aside president
trump's campaign is looking to shift
gears
after months of quarantine and isolation
for many followed by
weeks of protests some of which turned
violent some of the polling has not
looked too great for the
commander-in-chief
he's been questioned about everything
from his handling of the virus to
how u.s park police cleared protesters
out of lafayette square
before he took a picture in front of st
john's church
while the trump campaign has outraised
joe biden's campaign overall so far in
fundraising
biden and the dnc's numbers were nearly
even with the trump campaign and rnc
numbers in april
and biden's campaign reported a surge in
donations after the death of george
floyd
he delivered a taped message to mourners
at floyd's funeral service tuesday
why in this nation do too many black
americans
wake up knowing that they could lose
their life in the course of just living
their life
but now after a tumultuous few months
the trump campaign is looking to hit the
campaign trail again
and yes that means rallies the president
has been very eager to get back out on
the campaign trail and
rallies are really the way that he
connects with voters best in person
loud boisterous crowd tim murtaugh is
the senior communications director for
president trump's 2020 campaign he's
been wanting to to get back out there
and
we intend to do that sometime in the
next two weeks we'll announce
the next trump rally and i think the uh
the pent-up energy and the pent-up
enthusiasm uh will make this one uh one
of the one of the loudest most
boisterous
rallies yet you know and this it keeps
it keeps with the president's view that
america has to get back to being open
for business and back to action uh
having a trump rally
uh is really uh would be a message to
america
that we can get back to the way that
things were before the global pandemic
hit and it will also serve the purpose
of show the stark stark contrast between
the energy
of the trump campaign and his
re-election versus
sleepy joe biden who could only really
uh conjure up images of such a loud
enthusiastic crowd in his dreams you
talked about getting back to
normal like before like how it was
before the virus but
will it be or or will any sort of rally
be a little bit different will will
there be any sort of accommodations
with all the modifications that that are
supposed to be made because of the virus
or did the recent protests
sort of end the need for social
distancing in the campaign's mind
well brad parscale our campaign manager
is will be
very soon in the next day or so be
presenting the president with
a list of options for where the first
rallies could take place
and with you know we would
determinations for uh safety protocols
would be made
based on where the rally is and and what
type of venue it is
but you know i think we've seen the
national media
uh be sort of uh sitting from the
sidelines and shaming people about
social distancing and different
precautions that they view that people
have
have not taken when they you know you
see twitter videos of
uh people across the country who in the
media's view were were not doing
appropriate social distancing
there were no such concerns raised when
people were looking at the massive
protests so
the video comes to mind is one in
philadelphia over the weekend
and so we we feel as though that the
media really has forfeited
the right to be social distancing
shamers
when they they have they did not have
concerns with other large gatherings and
if they raise it for the president and a
rally for the president i think it would
show
a great contradiction and general
hypocrisy the protest that we're
referencing
right they were over the death of george
floyd i want to ask you about that
the president has met with law
enforcement and defended law enforcement
does the president need to say something
more
about how black people feel about racism
and the police
where where's the campaign on having the
president make an address to the nation
well i think the president has addressed
the nation twice
once in the last week and then again two
saturdays ago he has addressed the
nation
and specifically and at length addressed
the killing of george floyd the
president found it disgusting
and and horrific and he has been very
clear about that and so
the president has has repeatedly in
those two
sets of remarks speeches to the nation
and also in remarks that he's made at
the white house he had a round table
with law enforcement officers
and the president is very concerned
about what happened to george floyd and
does not want to see that sort of thing
happen again
of course but he also knows that
no one hates a bad cop more than a good
cop does
and he knows that 99.9 percent of the
men and women who wear the uniform and
go out and protect our communities every
single day are good people
upstanding members of those communities
who all they're doing every day is
laying their lives on the line
to protect their fellow citizens
president trump supports the police
absolutely and uh he does not want a few
bad apples to spoil the bunch
i i know he's tweeted that you know that
he's for law and order in all caps you
know not defunding police and for
responding
more strongly you know to the looting
and the rioting that we saw following mr
floyd's death
from from the campaign's perspective
though as you look at appealing to
and reaching out to you know that wider
swath of voters
is some more sympathy in order toward
you know how black folks are feeling and
what they're saying they're feeling
especially as some polling is indicating
that race relations are now moving
to the top of the priority list i mean
next to health care the president has
repeatedly expressed empathy and and uh
horror and sorrow at what happened to
george floyd and
and he understands those sentiments
among black americans there's no
question of that
however he also knows that if we are to
return to prosperity you can't do that
without peace without law and order in
those communities and then
look having the security to know that
you can be safe
in your own communities and be safe on
the streets means
having strong law enforcement and these
calls to defund the police or to
dismantle police departments this isn't
something that
the trump campaign made up this is a
real
movement within the democrat party the
democrat
defund the police train is leaving the
station
and joe biden is a hapless passenger on
that train whether he knows it or not
he may give lip service to the fact that
oh no i don't support defunding the
police
but elected officials in his party
people who are on his team are
supporters of his
visible elected supporters of joe
biden's are
leading this effort he could put a stop
to it he could say this is nonsense you
guys all well he did didn't he
he did say he doesn't support defunding
the police he did not he said he said i
do i don't support defunding the police
and then he said but what i do is i want
to attach conditions to those funds
with some amorphous undescribed
ill-defined
uh requirements on those on those things
on the funding let's talk about polling
i know you're not necessarily a huge fan
of of
pooling in terms of taking them all too
seriously
but it does look a little dicey in some
of the key swing states you know biden
is
up over the president and florida by a
few points if you look at some of those
polls and
and um i guess the latest polls out of
michigan have biden up anywhere from
two to 12 points i know that's quite a
spread and i also know it's still
kind of early but what do you guys make
of this well we never
ever put any stock in public polling and
uh polls were proven wrong if if public
polls were to be
or to be believed then hillary clinton
would be in the oval office right now
and if you just take a look at the cnn
poll that just came out
earlier this week and made a lot of news
that is the most ridiculous poll
that our team has ever seen and cnn
ought to be ashamed to have published it
in its sample
uh it counts only 25 percent of
republicans in their sample which is
ridiculously low it is in in
no way reflects the makeup of this
country and
also that was a poll of random adults
they didn't even screen
for registered voters uh fully 10 of the
people who were questioned in that poll
are not even registered voters what what
sort of poll is that that is trying to
uh inform the public no it is trying to
shape public opinion
it is trying to suppress the the support
for the president
by issuing such a poll it's gone and the
president the president he's hiring a a
firm to investigate that or to look into
that poll uh well i mean i think he was
referencing
our own existing pollster which is john
mclaughlin
who does who does uh the polls for for
the campaign already
um but every look the campaign knows we
know that our
own internal data has consistently over
months
shown that in the we we pay attention
specifically to 17 states that we
believe
uh will make the determination of who
the next president is in those 17 states
we know
that the president runs strong against
joe biden against a defined joe biden
the president did
recently thank republicans for
overwhelmingly supporting him
i think i saw that in a tweet i assume
that was based on
some polling data but how does the
campaign plan to like
fight any pac or biden ads put together
that
you know highlight some of the
republican
lack of support for the president like
from colin powell or general mattis or
even senator murkowski who's
publicly wondering if she can vote for
the president we know
from our own internal numbers and from a
number of public uh polls that the
president enjoys the support
of over well over 90 percent of
republicans over 90 percent of the
republicans it is
a historically united republican party
behind president trump and so
when we see these beltway figures inside
the beltway dc figures you know the the
adoration of the washington dc beltway
media
is a very powerful thing and is very
alluring to some people and so
you know we put no stock in that i know
the issue
for i want to talk about the the virus
really briefly i know the issue for a
while was
oh coronavirus and the response to it
you know that's going to be a huge part
of this election it's going to be a
referendum on how the president handled
it all
but now that things are reopening and
it's june and we're five months away
from the election
and protesters in in mostly blue states
suddenly gave up distancing and
really caring about those rules does
that reframe
things for for the for the campaign and
for this notion of a referendum on how
the virus was handled
every step along the way americans can
see that president trump was out front
in public very visibly
leading the nation through the
coronavirus crisis he acted early
he cut off travel from china early on
before the end of january
and at the time joe biden criticized him
for doing that saying it was xenophobic
and fear-mongering to do so
now of course joe biden wants to say
that he was the guy standing on the
rooftop
shouting for everybody to to lock down
and close the economy back in january
that's bogus joe biden if joe biden
really did do that and really did have
those thoughts
then why did he continue to campaign
normally into the second week of
march so americans know that the
president has been leading the country
through the coronavirus crisis and now
we know it is time to get the economy
back
open fully we saw the incredible news
last friday of the may jobs report
economists had predicted
eight and a half million job losses
for the month of may instead the economy
added
two and a half million jobs the
economists were only off by about 11
million
jobs in the wrong direction this is the
beginning of the great american comeback
tim martel thank you so much for your
time i appreciate it thank you
[Music]
this is robert jeffress with your fox
news commentary
coming up what a difference three months
makes
from the pandemic and the recession to
the movement
driven by george floyd's death for law
enforcement reform
we cannot settle for anything less than
transformative structural change but
house speaker nancy pelosi's version of
that
might not go far enough for younger
progressive members of her caucus
a split that could hurt moderate
democrats at the polls
as calls to defund police gain traction
though right now there's also more than
one version of what that means
i tend to put this in the same category
as
abolish ice and abolish
private insurance something that
mainstream democrats are going to reject
pretty pretty roundly chris stirewalt is
the fox news politics editor
you know there's always going to be
there's always going to be fringes
uh and the the challenge for a party is
always
can you harness the energy which is
always great
uh in the uh radical
set uh without peeling off uh
mainstream voters i think for
you you've seen the sort of the classic
steps of the walk back
where it's like well by defund the
police we what we mean
is fund the police but do it in a
different way you're like okay all right
well never mind then
uh so i think like we saw with medicare
for all
uh the green new deal any number of
things
that some democrats gave enthusiastic
ascent for in the beginning
uh just a little bit more just a little
more thinking
uh turn they realize that it's a
political loser
and and won't even achieve the goals
that they want and they ditch it
with everything that's happened in 2020
the pandemic the economic plunge
now the movement really for police
reform
what does that do to the battle for
control of the senate
so the the states where you have
competitive senate elections this cycle
um so you have arizona colorado uh
north carolina maine uh and those are
sort of the big four and then you look
and say okay well if this election got
tippy
one way or the other on the presidential
level then there's other states that
come into play
but we have to always remember that
these senate races will substantially be
a reflection
of the presidential race right like if
donald trump wins
arizona by five points uh martha
mcsally's gonna do a lot better
if uh president trump loses colorado by
15 points uh corey gardner is not going
to make it out right he's
there he'll he'll just get he'll just
get shut up in that in that coffin
so a lot of this is a reflection
of the of the national now you could
certainly say in a race like georgia
where these issues have been intense um
this is a race that is the republicans
should they have two senate races going
on in georgia
the one that we're watching most closely
is the one where there is a
horrible republican primary
uh between the incumbent uh kelly
loffler
and congressman doug collins they've
just been wasting
huge sums of money and attacking each
other uh
joe lieberman's son uh is among the
democrats looking to
uh to take on the the it's a jungle
primary system so everybody's gonna run
and then they're to run again
you could see how it could help
democrats down there if the if collins
especially if collins gets through
uh that the there is a an
increased concern among all americans
but also among republicans
about police brutality towards uh
african-american males there is like
it's a thing
and and you could see how in
a state like georgia how if the
republicans end up with collins after a
tough
primary uh that he could that this is an
issue that could hurt him
there have also been some states that
have been steadily
diversifying in their populations since
the republican gains
in the 2014 midterms and then
you have the president's issues with
support in the suburbs
women especially
if you contrast you know the freshman
gardener in colorado
with the veteran senator susan collins
of maine she's been there for over two
decades
someone who breaks with the president
sometimes but then sides with him
on some hot button issues like voting to
confirm brett kavanaugh to the u.s
supreme court
how much does it hurt a candidate like
collins when the president has this
issue
with support in the suburbs with support
with women collins has been here before
right every six years of susan's susan
collins career we say this may be
this may be the one right that takes her
out i don't know how she's going to
survive this one
but she has because she has established
a brand with mainers
as an independent person and they have a
senator who is an independent and angus
k
the other senator is independent angus
king maine
does not reward partisan loyalty
colin's fear though is that there will
be a backlash against
her for questioning the president and
that the state's republicans will stay
home
i think her real danger is that
democrats
who are really united and really
motivated this cycle are going to say no
more exceptions
she's got to go because of trump do you
think it's a harder year
for moderate republicans or moderate
democrats
so we're almost five months away
from the election at this point four
years ago
trump trailed hillary clinton by less
than three points
now trump trails biden by more than
eight points and swing state polls tell
the same story
uh he is materially worse off
uh demonstrably worse off than he was
four years ago so republicans have to
watch and wait and see
at some point if you are running for
senate if you're running for governor if
you're running for the house
at some point do you start to separate
yourself do you start to say you need to
keep me
because the democratic lunatics are
going to take over and i'm the only
thing that can protect you so one of the
things that we'll watch for
are uh whether republicans start
changing their messaging
as we go on and that'll depend on
whether trump can get things turned
around
i mean do these unusual times make it
any more likely
that people might split their ticket
vote against the president but still
vote in favor of an incumbent republican
senator
so ticket splitting is very rare these
days but
there is evidence to suggest that
in blowout elections and this is this is
a matter of some debate but there's
there's evidence to suggest
that in blowout elections uh
ticket-splitting increases
that would be a logical thing that would
happen right if a lot of people liked
um one candidate then so
to take the big blowout so in in years
like 1972
1984 1964 where you have routes
um and big wins yeah there's ticket
splitting now is that ticket splitting
defensive that is to say are people
voting are they intentionally splitting
their ticket
or are they voting one way on the
presidential and then just reverting to
their type
right for the rest of the ballot i'm a
republican
i'm a democrat i'm voting this way but
everybody knows in the presidential
we're voting for you know captain fun
bear rainbow pants who's just the best
and everybody loves him
so you could have that uh or you could
have the kind of strategic ticket
splitting where people say
i'm gonna vote for the other team for
president
so i better make sure that i vote for
the home team
on legislative races what about a
conflict with the president
in some of these key states could that
affect any of the senate races
like in north carolina where he's been
sparring with the governor
over convention rules or in alabama
where jeff sessions his former attorney
general
is trying to get his old seat back the
president's been backing sessions
primary opponent
former college football coach tommy
tuberville well i mean there's always
local issues i wouldn't spend too much
time thinking about alabama though
if you can get crimson tide fans to vote
for
uh a a former coach of auburn
uh you have demonstrated the
partisanship trump's all i don't think
doug jones is gonna
is going to have an uh a full term in
the senate uh
and i think everybody knows that um
the whole thing is if you're running for
the senate if you're running for
the house you want to just make sure
that you're
in in the zone where you can still win
right uh and this may push you this way
this may push you that way but if you're
somebody like tillis in north carolina
tom tillis is going to do about as well
in north carolina as donald trump i
would suppose
uh and so he wants to make sure that he
doesn't do anything
that hurts him on the underside there so
he's made his bet
and he's he's gonna ride it through but
it's mostly a top-down question sure
there's local stuff but it's a top-down
issue
one last thing we've got about five
months to go until the election but i i
saw it put a different way recently
you know less than 150 days
so that sounds like not a lot of time
left
is there enough time for you know
either side to still have a real chance
in november
of course where were we five months ago
five months is a very long time 150 days
is a very long time
especially in a media environment that
eats like a cowboy right
you know cowboy only has one dish so he
can only eat beans and he can only eat
uh
chuck and he can only eat that one thing
at a time so that's what we do we focus
on this and then we're like coronavirus
no no we're talking about police
brutality oh no so we we will have many
people who think that the circumstances
of this day
will be the circumstances of election
day have obviously not been paying
attention
if you would have told us six months ago
what the circumstances would be today
what the election would look like
how joe biden won the nomination what
we're talking about with conventions all
of these things
we would have said that's impossible and
yet here we are chris firewall
fox news politics editor and co-host of
the i'll tell you what podcast
thank you so much for your time power to
the people
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz
fox business's liz clayman talks with
entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
robert jeffress
what's on your mind on may 22nd
president trump observed
in america we need more prayer not less
in light of recent events i couldn't
agree more
now perhaps more than ever christians
need to come together to pray for
america
our houses of worship are essential
places providing essential services
and we must begin the process of
returning to our churches
in a safe way almost every church in
america has been shut down for months
even on easter sunday the president
pointed out that it's not right for some
governors
to allow liquor stores and abortion
clinics to reopen
but require churches to remain shuttered
when he boldly stood up for religious
liberty by calling for america's
churches to reopen
that resonated with millions of
believers around the country
after the president's remarks he called
me and made
it very clear that he's not asking for
churches to open capriciously
it ought to be done carefully and it
needs to be done
now of course each congregation needs to
make wise decisions according to their
individual situations at my church first
baptist dallas
we have been very cautious about this
from the beginning we have said that we
are going to be
data driven not date driven we heeded
the advice of our federal
state and local authorities recently we
observed an overall plateau in the
number of covid 19 cases
in our area and a decline in the
percentage
of positive cases to overall tests
based on these metrics we prayerfully
decided to partially reopen
on june 7th our church opened at 20
capacity using a reservation system
in our contactless service we didn't
exchange
printed programs or pass offering plates
instead we provided receptacles for
offerings
and decision cards we encouraged social
distancing and placed hand sanitizing
stations
throughout our campus we also strongly
encouraged everyone to wear
face masks now just because
churches begin gradually reopening
doesn't mean
it is right for everyone to attend at
first baptist dallas
we encourage those who have underlying
health issues
or feel they're especially susceptible
to this virus
to stay home we also stream our live
services on our website regardless of
whether people worship with us in person
or at home they are an important part of
our church
now we've seen that tensions are high as
people begin to go out
into the community i think one word that
needs to characterize the
way we interact during this time is
grace
all believers need to exercise grace
love and understanding toward one
another especially in this transitional
reopening process but it's clear that
christians across america
are ready to get back to in-person
worship
in a safe atmosphere and it's time for
our nation's churches
to reopen this is robert jeffress pastor
of the first baptist church in dallas
fox news contributor and author of the
new book
courageous
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast
at foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist
for the latest episodes